[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new guardians of the
galaxy 3 video james gunn revealed some
new hidden easter eggs so i'll break it
all down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite easter egg from
a marvel movie on the video
so starting with number five if you
don't know what's going on this past
week james gunn revealed some more
secret easter eggs from guardians of the
galaxy movies
there has been an ongoing contest that
he put the fans to find as many easter
eggs as possible claiming that no one
had discovered
all the easter eggs yet just because his
knowledge of comic books
and film is so deep he bakes in so many
easter eggs into the backgrounds of his
marvel movies
that it takes years to find them all the
first guardians 3 easter egg actually
starts with guardians 2.
so in this scene here where the
guardians are being chased by the
sovereign after their first big fight
they wind up crash landing on the planet
burr herd
bur herd is actually an anagram for
herbert as in herbert wyndham aka the
high evolutionary
we haven't seen him before in the marvel
cinematic universe he's been one of the
rumored big marvel face four villains
that they'll introduce at some point
there are a lot of really weird s-tier
marvel villains from the comics that
they haven't done in the movies that
have been rumored for marvel phase four
the high evolutionary is just one of
them just because of the way he's tied
to the guardians of the galaxy
if you haven't watched any of the
animated series disney did an animated
guardians of the galaxy show after the
first movie blew up they actually did a
version of the high evolutionary on that
series they got involved with adam
warlock and the guardians
so even though adam warlock is being
pitched as one of the villains of
guardians 3
technically he's not the main villain
technically he's not a villain at all
he's just an antagonist for a little
while because in the comics he's
actually a pretty good character and
becomes a member of the guardians of the
galaxy
eventually number four james gunn said a
long time ago that rocket raccoon was
one of the most important characters and
guardians of the galaxy 3
and the movie would be the culmination
of the original cast's
story arcs in the trilogy so some of the
cast members might not return for future
marvel movies some of them probably will
come back though like chris pratt said
that he wants to be in as many marvel
movies as they'll have him for so
whatever they do in the future of marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5 chris pratt will
come back as star-lord
yes you of course
of course of course all that really
funny thor asgardians of the galaxy
stuff will carry over into guardians 3
as well
but i think it's going to be relatively
minor based on the way they're talking
about it
they have shuffled some of the way that
story is going to play out too because
originally guardians 3
was supposed to be released before thor
4 love and thunder
now it's the other way around so it'll
all make a little more sense i'll do
more thor
4 videos in the future too talking about
what's going on with asgardians of the
galaxy stuff because it's a little bit
separate from this easter egg video
but james gunn said that dealing with
past trauma is a big part of all their
different story arcs
most of the focus has been on peter
quill's childhood trauma of losing his
mother and not knowing who his father
was
they dealt with that primarily during
the first guardians movie in guardians
of the galaxy 2 with ego the living
planet
so heading into guardians 3 they're just
focusing more on rocket and some of the
other characters like nebula and gamora
the younger version of gamora that they
stole from 2014
who are still dealing with the father
issues that they have after avengers end
game with thanos
early on in the first guardians movie
they give you a hint of rocket's secret
backstory
in the lineup they tease half world
where he came from that's where he was
experimented on and forcibly evolved
into his current state
in the comics you don't really see much
from the people who genetically altered
all the animals there but there are a
lot of other different types of talking
animals who can walk around like humans
i know there's a lot of rumors about
them doing the lila character who's sort
of his romantic interest from the comics
but if the guardians franchise is all
about dealing with traumatic experiences
in bad marvel dads the whole idea of
guardians 3 is that rocket deals with
his own version of a bad dad
i know there's been a lot of rumors
about him possibly dying after james
gunn made a bunch of posts about death
being an important part of dramatic
story arcs in
all movies they kill at least one core
team member in all the guardians movies
groot sacrificed himself in the first
movie yondu died in the second movie
so if someone has to die in the third
movie it might be rocket finally doing
the selfless thing and sacrificing
himself to save all of his friends that
he spends
so much time cursing yondu kind of took
him to task about that during guardians
telling him he understood why he's being
such an ass to everyone because i used
to be
just like you i know them scientists
what made you
never gave a rat's ass about number two
the next big easter egg james gun
revealed is actually a retcon easter egg
not something he initially planned on
putting into the movie at least
intentionally
sometimes fans will see some connections
or something in the background that the
director didn't remember
riding into the movie initially but
subconsciously there is some easter egg
there that they acknowledge
after the fact so this past weekend a
fan on twitter asked him about his young
son's
fan theory that baby groot was eating
candy in this scene using the pot
that rocket had put him in when he was
still a twig the dancing baby groot meme
from the end of the first movie
james gunn admitted that he didn't think
of that when they were making guardians
2 but he liked it so
much in the connection that he made it
canon on the spot so now it's officially
an easter egg in the movie
stuff like this happens all the time one
of the most famous examples is
spider-man and iron man 2. the exact
same situation happened with the fan
theory that tom holland and kevin feige
were talking about during the press tour
for spider-man homecoming a couple years
ago
tom holland really liked the theory that
this young kid in the iron man mask was
actually peter parker who had just
happened to be visiting the stark expo
which was located in queens the borough
of new york city where he lives with
aunt may
fun fact also at this time uncle ben
would have still been alive even though
we don't know what he looks like in the
mcu
a lot of fan theories about that now
that we have spider verse that sony is
working on
a lot of people hoping that toby maguire
might wind up being the uncle ben of the
mcu
if sam raimi is making doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness maybe he can do us
a solid and canonize that
but kevin beige liked the iron man
spider-man idea so much that he
canonized it on the spot so even though
john favreau
who made the film didn't plan on it that
way when they were making iron man 2
now it's canon in actuality the actor
playing that little kid in the mask was
also john favreau's son
in real life at the time he put his son
in the movie twice because the kid in
the mask
shows up at the beginning of the movie
too there have been all of vin diesel's
comments about the alpha
version of groot during guardians 3
that's just the next evolution of groot
obviously he's
teenage group during avengers end game
he was baby group before that so he just
implied that he'll slowly grow up
into his most evolved form by the end of
these character arcs
james gonna try to downplay it a little
bit i think just to try and avoid
spoilers because he wasn't expecting vin
diesel to give this way in an interview
that happened a little while ago when he
was doing interviews for bloodshot just
trying to hype people up for guardians 3
because he's so pumped up himself
groot is another one of those characters
that i'm hoping will come back in future
marvel movies but that just depends on
vin diesel signing a new contract with
marvel but because it's a voice over
role it's not quite as demanding as a
physical on-screen performance
but now that they're doing the fully
grown alpha version of groot in the new
movies
maybe they will put vin diesel back in a
mocap suit
they did a little bit of that during the
first movie because it was the bigger
version of groot and vin diesel even
came to the premiere wearing groot
stilts like this
the number one the final new easter egg
is actually another big one
james gunn revealed while he was busy
canonizing the groot
easter egg this one is even cooler
because he revealed the bigger secret
that the post-credit scene of stan lee's
cameo with the watchers
was itself influenced by the fans of the
earlier marvel movies
but it's not a retroactive easter egg
this is something that he intentionally
wrote into the movie
and filmed this way so in the stanley
cameo scenes with the watchers he's
explaining all of his cameo scenes in
the events of the other marvel movies so
far
a lot of people wondered if he was a
watcher himself in the movie he's
officially credited as an agent of the
watchers so you could think of him as a
cosmic figure
but that means that stan lee in real
life or a person who looks like
stan lee works with the watchers in the
marvel universe
tasked with observing the events of all
the movies but that's not the end of it
on the surface that was just a really
cool easter egg that tied together all
of his cameo scenes everybody loved it
everyone was going crazy about it after
the movie came
out but the bigger secret is that james
gunn revealed he only wrote it that way
because of fan theories that stan lee
was playing the same character
in all of his cameo scenes so stan lee
being part of the watchers
started out as a fan thing that then
became official canon to the mcu
still probably one of the coolest easter
eggs in any marvel movie so far the fact
that stan lee
himself is the same character in all
these different movies
obviously they're never going to replace
stan lee and they're not going to try to
replace him
but if they do start giving someone
special cameo scenes in multiple
different movies let me know in the
comments who do you want that to be
right now black widow is still currently
supposed to come out in november
falcon and winter soldier and one
division episodes are still supposed to
be released later this year
so there is some big stuff to look
forward to and there is comic con
happening
this month and next month between marvel
and dc
marvel hasn't officially announced what
their marvel phase 4 comic con panel is
going to be
or if they're going to do their own
separate thing separate from comic con
congratulations kid gravity beyond
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the about
page of my channel so i can get your
contact details
while you wait for everything everyone
click here for that brand new stranger
things
season 4 trailer and click here to watch
hugh jackman break down
all the marvel wolverine movies thank
you so much
you